Kellie's with us in Springfield Mass hey
Kelly how are you I'm great how are you
Dave better than I deserve what's up
okay so I've read all your books and I
took your SPU class and I fully have
your 20% head knowledge I cannot get the
behavior down what do I do
how old are you 34 okay are you single
I'm married okay
um is your husband on board with these
ideas I finally got him on board the son
where with your plans and we're trying
to do it together where we put our money
for the first time together since we've
been married and that's been 11 years
that's good okay so um when you say you
can't do the behavior what is it that
you can't do um we still we're like
complete both free spirits we eat out
all the time we spend money on things
that we probably shouldn't we love going
to flea market fun we've done so we've
done so much better we've come a long
way but we still keep messing up um I
agree with one thing in your plan but
then he disagrees with something on your
plan but we fight about it and then you
know he ones $100 a week for pocket cash
and he says well I worked two jobs
I deserve it we're still doing that call
the wambulance she works hard poor
little boy he works hard
that's sweet like the rest of us don't
give me a break
seriously man um well here's the thing
you guys are I've got to decide why
you're doing this why are you why are
you trying to get control of your money
we are I'm 34 he's 36 and we filed
bankruptcy twice in our lives already
we're trying to avoid doing it again
okay
so so if you don't file bankruptcy
what would be the benefit what is it
that happens in your life that's good
I finally get control of my money yeah
so for what why um you know I've never
had control my family's never had
control why do you want control of your
money what are you gonna do with it I
just want a savings account why are you
going to do with it nothing that's the
plan that's the problem this is why you
can't stop changing your behaviors
because you don't have any why you're
why is so vague you need to write down
we want to change our family tree I
don't want my children to grow up and be
stupid like I have been that's what I
wrote down when I went broke because I
was stupid when American Express called
my wife and asked her why she would stay
with a man they wouldn't pay his bills I
swore that day I would never have
another phone conversation with American
Express unless it was a wrong number
you got it I got it
I was done why because I didn't want to
be back there ever again I'm gonna
change my family tree we're never gonna
be here again and see you you think you
know somehow you're playing with us like
it's an intellectual game it's got to
get visceral for you and for him and
then he'll quit whining about the fact
that he works you follow me I thought
cuz I work I work too but I don't need
to work anymore but I work I work like a
crazy person because I love what I do
and because I'm working for bigger goals
than just money nowadays and so you know
you just got to have a why and why I
work is not $100 pocket money because I
work hard why I work is because I want
to hit some goals I don't ever want to
be here again ever ever and we're going
to change our family tree and and then
you need to write down in detail using
every dollar online get your detailed
budget and then the two of you look at
that and go this is what we're doing and
I didn't see flea markets on there this
is what we're doing we're not doing
anything that's not on this list this is
what we're doing with our money
and and then when one of you starts
acting like you're four years old again
and and whining then you don't know
we're being grown-ups adults devise a
plan and follow it children do what
feels good these are the kinds of
conversations I had to have with me I'm
not fussing at you Kelly but this is me
looking in the mirror at Dave going look
you idiot you got to change your life
and we drew a line the same we said
that's it
never again never again and he's got to
have that same trip take that same trip
with you
because right now you're just
babysitting a child I think we're both
children beyond it well we all are I am
too down inside of me I mean how can I
can impulse or see something I like or
you know get out of control or or get a
goal that I think is bigger than the
amount of money that I have all of us
have that ability and so this is about
you know appealing to the but you also
have an adult side to you and adults
devise a plan and follow it children do
what feels good and so you got to look
around go you know this freakin ain't
work and it's a dr. Phil moment how is
it working for you you know it's not
right and so you know we've had two
bankruptcies we fight about money we are
not winning we're not getting traction
something's got to change here and
you've got to have that I've had it
moment and then look clearly into the
future and say hey I want to be I want
to have this house paid off and on my
house free and clear by X date I want to
have this debt that we've got cleared up
by X date and start setting some
detailed goals with numbers and then
when you say hey I want to go out to eat
you go well we really can't because
we're trying to get the house paid off
by X date we're trying to get this cut
because we want to change our lives you
got to have a big enough thing that's
bigger than the going out to eat because
that what's happening is that your
impulses aren't as big as your nobility
you got to get your nobility bigger so
that your impulses shrink and in the
sight of your nobility usually what I'm
talking about I do and and that that's
an emotional maturity thing and you can
choose that you can just decide just
like that I just decided and and he can
decide just like that and and and yeah
he works hard I want him to have
something for it
and 100 bucks a week depending on your
household income 100 bucks a month
pocket money's not a big deal depending
on your household income that might not
keep you from hitting your goals but the
fact that he says all I work hard I
deserve money I mean that's just--that's
that's an indicator where you guys are
so you've got to look out there and look
for something that's big a big hairy
audacious goal of be hag it's what jim
collins calls it and when you got a b
hag you will do anything and it's like I
saw a bumper sticker the down a car said
nothing tastes as good as it feels to be
thin and then you go look it's just more
fun to be thin than it is to be cramming
food in my mouth all the time I had a
friend of mine lost 38 pounds of summer
and he you know I was talking to him
about it he said you know I just
realized that nobody sneaks into my
bedroom at night duct-tapes me to the
bed and feeds force-feed me chocolate
chip cookies because I'm a victim not of
anything except my own inability to
control me self-discipline it's hard
though
I agree Kelly it's hard all I can tell
you is it's worth it and you got to do
it you got to do it so you call me back
tell me how you're doing
I love to hear from you thanks for
calling in hey guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you enjoyed that video from the
Dave Ramsey show if you want to watch
another great video check out my video
three things you should consider renting
right over here or click the link in the
description below